all right let's get right into audience
questions for the week I understand what
is on people's minds and it explains why
these are the questions I've gotten
first one is hey David what is the
longest that the United States can
realistically stay shut down because of
coronavirus so I'm gonna answer the
question as asked but please understand
that we never really shut down to the
degree that Europe did and when you look
at you know 4.8% GDP decline in q1
that's that's a lot that's crazy but
that's an economy that's mostly still
open now okay the shutdowns didn't start
until March if we have a 20 percent
decline in q2 April May June that is
crazy that's a crazy but consider that
that still means eighty percent of the
economy is still up and running so
compared to Europe the United States
restrictions have been really light the
stay home orders have been put in place
in a number of states essential stores
are still open for the most part you
know all grocery stores hardware stores
in Massachusetts restaurants remained
open for take-out people could go around
not wearing masks outdoors and even
indoors for a long time
you could go wherever you want parks
were open some places have had to close
parks because of people gathering a lot
of beaches remained open as long as
people weren't on top of each other in
Italy just this week people started to
be allowed to go more than 200 meters
from their house or fight I think in
Spain it was 500 meters we never had
that in the United States even in the
strictest situations wherever I don't
know if we would consider Michigan to
have been the strictest or whatnot but
we were never really fully shut down and
a lot of what we saw in the u.s. is
really a City versus suburban suburb
rural distinction because I've been in
Boston restaurants remained open for
take-out but the streets are quite empty
there's like very little traffic going
places so certainly the more urban areas
of the city seem noticeably empty but a
lot of the basics stayed open the entire
time suburbs
not even have been as dramatically
different I it's hard for me to say for
sure so the answers in terms of how much
longer can we stay quote shut down it's
very clear that there is not a lot of
political appetite even in the more
liberal states to stay shut even a
single day longer than public health
officials say that we should so I think
we're increasingly going to start seeing
two tiers we were going to start to see
places that had early hot spots and took
it very seriously New York and
Massachusetts in California are the ones
I'm most familiar with that in the next
two weeks to four weeks two to three
weeks are going to be able to start
opening some things with caution
still with masks indoors outdoors when
you can't social distance but there will
be some opening up more than likely
manufacturing hopefully can start to
come back with people wearing masks and
distancing in factories etc the
governor's will sort of figure it out
the problem is that we are starting to
see rapidly rising cases in places like
Florida Georgia Texas and there are
others although I don't have the numbers
readily sort of in my mind and on a
percentage basis they are seeing faster
and faster increases in cases they're
not going to be able to open up or if
they do it is going to be significantly
tragic significantly tragic so you have
some states starting to say we're going
to start running out of unemployment
insurance money that's going to be
pressure especially for Republican
governors who are very concerned with
debt in this abstract sense to try to
open up the saddest part about all of it
and ultimately these are decisions that
governors will have to make and the
answer as many of them are going to
start opening some things in the next
two to three weeks sadly if on March 5th
when we had over 200 cases Trump had
said from the federal government I need
all 50 governors to do a
shelter-in-place stay at home order we
had done that on March 5th we would be
in really good shape right now that's
what we're seeing in other countries
South Korea took care of things despite
having their first case at the same time
we did and that is that is the really
lost opportunity that there's no way to
go back and on
do at this point in time